what i want to do in this video is think
about why it's so hard for a
monopolistic
monopolistic competitor to make money in
the long run
and just as a reminder monopolistic
competitors much closer to perfect
competition than it is to a monopoly
what it means is that you have a
monopoly on your differentiated product
but eventually other people are going to
make substitute products they can't make
exactly your product it can't be
identical and it might eat into your
demand and to understand that let us
draw the demand curve
for
for a market in which
in which monopolistic competition is
going on
i'll draw it nice and big and so on this
axis right over here i'm going to plot
dollars per dollars per unit and so
price is revenue per unit and we'll have
cost per unit and things like that and
in this axis i'm going to have quantity
produced in a given period of time and
we're going to speak in fairly general
terms over here
now let's assume
let's assume that our monopolistic
competitor right over here is apple and
its ipads apple ipads and i want to i
want to emphasize i'm not making any
acquisition accusations that apple is a
monopolist here they just have a
differentiated product and so they are
monopolistic competitors here they have
a monopoly in ipads they don't have a
monopoly in tablet computers or in
computers in general but only they can
sell ipads and so let's draw the demand
curve in the short run for ipads and
i'll make it linear to make things
simple
let me draw a little bit better than
that so let's say the demand curve looks
something like that
so that is our demand curve and we know
that if that's the demand curve and and
remember we're talking about the the
market for ipads not the market for
talbot computers apple is a monopolist
in the market for ipads so its marginal
revenue will have twice the slope of the
smart of this demand curve so it will
look something like
that
that is apple's marginal revenue curve
and then think about its short run
economic profits in a given period of
time whatever this quantity per period
of time is let's draw its costs so first
i'll draw
let me draw its marginal costs so its
marginal cost might look something like
this
that is their marginal cost and then to
do average total costs
up here when you have very low quantity
most of your costs are fixed costs but
you're dividing it by a very small
quantity so you're going to have a very
high average total cost it's going to
get lower and lower and lower as long as
the cost on each incremental unit is
lower than the average and the cost on
each incremental unit is a marginal cost
curve
so as long as the total average total
cost is higher than the marginal cost
curve
then you're going that's going to be
downward sloping and at some point
they're going to be equal to each other
and now each incremental unit that you
add on is going to increase the average
because the it's each incremental unit's
cost is more than the average so it's
going to cause everything to average
it's going to cause everything to
average up and this actually right over
here should be the minimum point
on our average total cost curve so given
the way i've drawn things what is
apple's short run economic profit
well we just have to think about its
optimal quantity to produce
so it's definitely going to produce one
the marginal revenue much higher than
the marginal cost is going to make
economic profit on that unit it's going
to keep producing because that continues
to be true continues to be true all the
way into this point right over here and
it doesn't want to produce more than
that because then the cost the econo the
opportunity cost on each incremental
unit is higher than the revenue on that
so you're going to take an economic loss
so you're going to produce right over
there
and at that quantity so i'll call that q
star right over there at that quantity
this is the price that they can charge
in the market going to the demand curve
i just went straight up to the demand
curve over there this is the price that
they can charge in the market and their
average or you could view that as their
average revenue per unit and then we
have our average cost per unit right
over here in average total cost so this
is their average economic profit per
unit and if we multiply that times the
total number of units
if we multiply times the total number of
units the area
of this rectangle right over here is
going to give total economic profit
total
total economic
economic
economic profit now in all things if
someone if the rest of the world sees
economic profit there's like wow that's
a good you know people are doing better
in that market than their opportunity
costs and so other competitors well i
can't produce ipads but i can start
making competitive products so you'll
see players like samsung and we are
seeing this sitting here in 2012 and
this is kind of a work in progress for
these competitors right over here
samsung
htc
um hp all the tablet manufacturers all
the computer manufacturers and they're
pairing up they're pairing up with the
operating system manufacturers like
microsoft
microsoft and google's google's android
and they're making competitive products
and
on top of it they are marketing it
they're marketing it heavily
they are marketing they're trying to
market the products as aggressively as
possible and so as their products become
more and more comparable to an ipad or
maybe even better in certain dimensions
either cost or features and they market
it heavily in the long run what's going
to happen to apple's demand curve well
at any given price less will be demanded
and so the demand curve will shift the
demand curve will shift to the left and
so we could end up with a new demand
curve i'm doing a different shade of
blue that looks something that looks
something like
that looks something like that so this
is our new
new demand curve or we should say maybe
our long run demand curve after these
people have made their products better
and have marketed heavily
if that's the new long run demand curve
then our long run marginal revenue curve
was going to have twice the slope of
that so it's going to look something
like this so if it's twice the slope
it's going to hit the line it's going to
go hit right about
it's going to look i can do a better job
than that
so our new marginal revenue let me do a
slightly different color i'll do it in
pink our new marginal revenue curve will
look something like that
so this is long run marginal revenue
long run
marginal revenue curve and so now what
is the optimal quantity for apple to
produce
well now it's going to make it's going
to make economic profit economic profit
economic profit all the way until this
point right over here so now we have
this new i'll call it long run
long run quantity or maybe i'll call it
let me do it a different color i'm using
that pink too much long run quantity
right over there
and to figure out the revenue per unit
or the price and that at that quantity
we just go up to the demand curve our
new demand curve remember our long run
demand curve it's right over there it
looks like at least the way i've drawn
it that the price hasn't changed much
we've got the same price but now what is
our average economic profit per unit
well the way i've drawn it the average
total costs right over there are right
about what that price is so our average
economic pro economic profit per unit
goes down to zero there is over here we
had this nice green height now we have
no height anymore and even though we're
selling a good number of units our
average economic profit per unit is zero
so instead of an area over there we're
going to have the area of a line which
is essentially zero so now we have zero
zero economic
economic
zero
economic profit so the important thing
to realize from a monopolistic
competitor this wouldn't happen
overnight i mean some would argue that
sitting here in 2012 early 2012 apple is
still generating economic profit and
it's always important to realize
economic profit is different than
accounting profit accounting profit can
be positive economic profit can be
zero when accounting profit is positive
so if you're if you have if you're
running you can even have an economic
loss
and still have accounting profit but
some people would argue that right now
apple is still making profits above and
beyond even their opportunity cost and
this is actually a work in progress
right now in 2012 that these that the
demand curve is shifting to the left but
eventually it all of the economic profit
will be eaten up and there will be less
incentive for all of these players to be
as aggressive so the important thing to
realize with the monopolistic competitor
is sure they their their curves look
like a monopolist but the competition
doesn't happen in terms of supply of
ipads none of these players can supply
ipads the competitive part happens with
all of these people producing
substitutes and being aggressive about
it and eating into the monopolistic
competitor's demand